I have some truly horrible news today
the American car industry is crumbling
under Donald Trump and Trump's
administration and I'm sort of in a
weird place on this because I admit I
haven't owned an American car since I
was in high school and had a Jeep Grand
Cherokee because quite frankly I've
never thought American cars were that
great and I still don't but my personal
opinion doesn't really matter in the
context of I mean I don't want American
car companies to fail because I
understand their importance to the
American economy I understand that a ton
of jobs depend on the car industry
including not only the jobs at the car
manufacturers themselves but at the
ancillary industries that are producing
components for cars and under Donald
Trump the American car industry is
increasingly falling apart and this
includes just disastrous news from both
Ford and General Motors and I'm going to
explain to you what has been announced
and I'll also explain to you how there's
an attempt to couch it as just a really
great thing when it's really not so
let's start with GM GM announced in the
last 24 hours that they are going to
layoff 15% of their salaried workers 15%
of their salaried workforce will be laid
off 25% of executives are going to be
laid off and they are going to stop
production at five plants in the United
States and Canada now not every detail
is disastrous and not every detail
relates to Donald Trump we can have a
sort of more holistic understanding of
what's going on here so for example part
of what GM is doing is they're no longer
going to produce cars that don't do well
and they're gonna refocus on
self-driving vehicles on electric
vehicles the waves of the future more
efficient trucks and that's going to
require moving some resources around
that part was well received including by
the stock market why because General
Motors is going to save a ton of money
when you layoff 15% of your workforce
you save a ton of money so for
shareholders this could actually
be ok but 15% of GM salaried workers are
going to be losing their jobs and you've
got an Ohio for example the Democratic
and the Republican senators Brown and
Portman respectively as well as friend
of the show congressman Tim Ryan who's a
Democrat they're all pointing out wait a
second Trump promised jobs would be
coming back but they're actually leaving
and then you've got the Trump tariffs on
steel and on aluminum and these are
impacting not just General Motors but
also Ford and I want to talk about Ford
in this context as well
Ford is straight-up having a terrible
year okay their stock price is down
about 30% Trump's tariffs have cost Ford
about a billion dollars and again Trump
thinks that he puts tariffs on China
so China pays that's wrong he puts
tariffs on Chinese goods
so therefore American companies using
those Goods pay so what is Ford doing
basically the same thing as GM they're
cutting a ton of jobs around 12% of its
workforce that's about 24,000 jobs
worldwide many in the United States so
yes a lot of this is systemic
self-driving cars are coming the
revolution that will be self-driving
cars is going to be impacting many areas
climate change is an area most people's
cars are parked something like 80 to 95
percent of the time think about if you
own a car how much of a day that car is
being driven versus how much of that
time is parked imagine if people who
drive I don't know an hour a day half an
hour to work half an hour back or 20
minutes to work 20 minutes back in 20
minutes for errands or whatever imagine
if instead of each of those people
having a car they simply had a car
available for that hour a day that they
need think about the reduction in
emissions think about the reduction in
car accidents think about the reduction
in traffic so this is a major major
revolution and car companies are
preparing they're moving to electric but
tariffs now to make their
businesses increased costs you've got to
understand that while that may all be
the inevitable way things will go in the
long term Trump said he was going to
reinvigorate the auto industry he was
going to bring back manufacturing jobs
and of course now you have a situation
where both Ford and GM are going to say
well a lot of this is restructuring it's
preparing for the future and that's all
true but it's all happening at the
expense of jobs which Trump said he
would bring back this is not a time for
tariffs this is a time for subsidies on
what we want these companies doing it's
time for subsidies on electric vehicles
subsidies on research for other fuels
and we've got to get rid of the
subsidies on oil help these companies
and then of course you have to remember
that a lot of the people that are being
hardest hit by this people in the
Midwest middle-class working-class white
people those that believe Trump was
going to be their guy they supported
Trump's election and they seem to be
still supporting Donald Trump and this
is sort of like the biggest takeaway we
all knew Trump didn't really know how to
bring back manufacturing jobs we knew
that he wasn't going to bring back
manufacturing jobs but what we're
learning is he doesn't actually seem to
care about the people that are losing
these jobs and the question is and we're
gonna address it on the Friday show are
we going to see working-class white
people in the Midwest move away from the
Republican Party that has been an
important demographic group for the
Republican Party and on the Friday show
we actually get an audience question
about which demographic groups do I
think might move away from the
Republican Party and I think that if
they start doing what's good for them
rural and and working class even urban
working class whites in the Midwest
really should be abandoning Trump in the
Republican Party we'll deal with that
more on Friday but in the interim really
just genuinely bad news from the car
industry which is horrible to see